hey I'm Steven Yeun I'm Jermaine Fowler
I'm army hammer okay what is army
hammers blank wife's name real name is
armie hammer this one's long his army
hammer as smart and funny and charming
as he seems to be yes a weird place what
what like that's what what does armie
hammer eat for dinner I'll go with that
what Heights army hater
okay what height are you six five okay
cool where does army him a live where is
army hammer from well they go to
Wikipedia yeah where are you from I was
born in LA LA yeah okay she needs around
a lot but ended up back early okay is
armie hammer I really do I mean I have
no game so they can get rushing a lot I
am I am rush yeah alright my dad my
dad's Russian yeah of course
yeah okay I mean the internet sleuths
are really on it does army has our
hammer skateboard use shampoo it looks
like does armie hammer where does he
live we need help
by the way does armie hammer where is
even creepier where do you live I can't
wait for this one does armie hammer I
mean this is getting weird now
exclamation point played both twins
armie hammer played both from social
network yeah yeah we're getting a little
loose on the rules of grammar come here
this armie hammer box that's a long box
yeah have a Twitter oh yes yes I do what
is it this is army hammer at armie
hammer
like I know you better from this this is
basically all you need to know about me
yeah there's nothing else of where does
he live
that one really creeps me out you know
what this is grating it has to be asked
enough to make it to the list which
means that people are like does arming
hammer where does he live a lot I want
to see Stevens list well does he know
where does art mean okay I'll go through
this it's gonna be bad google time it's
gonna be really bad
how do you things to be pronounced
Steven yawns last name okay how do you
pronounce no but if you get too many
right they know you google yourself this
this last name is the bane of my
existence it makes everyone into like an
Asian twang enthusiast but it's like
it's just young but they try to add like
zest to it yeah yeah yeah but it's just
you know you know so quit asking does
Steve know Steven Yeun exfoliate play
League of Legends hey this is very
specific to do you do a lot of gaming I
I mean I play like - are you our
generation gaming you just you know you
seem like the type
yeah where did Stephen grow up grow up
all right I grew up in Michigan in Troy
Michigan does Steven Yeun yeah wooly
eight hasn't really anything you know
guys he exfoliates actually don't
exfoliate you don't exfoliate look later
speak Korean yeah I know that means
hello I know how much ya oh I learned
some today what does Steven Yeun eat for
old age Drive woody drew Andrew I Drive
like a normal black sedan I'm sometimes
mistaken for overs this car seat is
Steven Yeun and uber driver in the Jake
from State Farm commercial you know what
this is why we need more Asian people on
the everybody thinks I play all
the Asian people on television
they think I play all of them I'm like
that guy's like that guy's not a guy and
walking down you know what make sure
we're getting to some real right
this is like since 1922 oh you got time
live your life be comfortable with
yourself also I'm not all the Asians on
TV all right
Jermaine Fowler in Atlanta all right
let's get in orange is the new black oh
yeah this interview I'm not orange new
black this joke I played on people that
I was crazy as an orange new black
because of my hair Jermaine Fowler his
real name yeah okay you know all that
stuff that's cool why do you do is a
great guy very smart person so no but
thank you very much how how how does
Jamaican his hair so beautiful oh I'm 29
I was born in 88 what up but that's my
age thank you for asking where's your
Ella from okay let's see I was born in
Northwest DC Howard University Hospital
I'm from Hyattsville Maryland that's the
hometown without the glitch is gonna be
the last one so probably a weird one
goddamn is Jermaine Fowler seven foot to
marry no I'm not married by appreciated
a good Christian folks I think we need a
new campaign of like internet PSAs I'm
not crazy I yeah from we're just like
don't believe everything you hear on
and stop looking where I live